what can I say about the most despised
movie prequel in cinema history well I
can say this who has two thumbs and
totally saw it coming
this guy that's right I've been waiting
years for these bragging rights and now
it's finally come I knew from the first
trailer that this was gonna be a bad
movie it just came down to logical
deduction
Lucas only directed one Star Wars Vil
and as impressive as it was it had a lot
of problems the writing was hokey the
acting was stilted and there's a lot of
things that didn't always make sense but
he had a lot of people to give him
advice and limitations so it still
turned out a good product then years
later after barely directing a thing
this guy is suddenly supposed to direct
a masterpiece though in all fairness
even I couldn't guess it'd be this bad
it starts all his obi-wan and his master
are trying to figure out some sort of
political Taxation Federation stuff that
yeah like you I can't figure out either
they try to help the newly-elected child
Queen Amidala which you don't elect
Queens and queens can't be children but
whatevs
and along the way they come across the
death of comedy Jar Jar Binks and the
death of acting and akin Skywalker
Anakin it turns out as a virgin birth it
can't get any more obvious than that and
according to a blood test apparently the
force is very strong with him oh the
amount of people this pissed off Oh
we'll get to that later they by Anakin
from one stereotype to deliver him to
two other stereotypes we're in cahoots
with a senator named Palpatine who is
secretly the Emperor who wants to get
the Queen to sign the treaty because
political stuff we get sword fights
gunfight space battles and through all
of it I have no idea what they're
fighting for
but who cares right in the original is
just an evil empire we didn't really
know their politics they were just kind
of evil so maybe we can just do the same
thing here right well that would work if
the characters were the least bit
interesting and by God are they not my
complaints are your complaints the
acting is so wooden the writing so
fifth-grade the effects way too
computer-generated the comedy way too
kinder
the stereotypes way too offensive yeah
what else can I say about this that
every other person on the planet hasn't
said well I guess I'll try to defend it
a touch as everybody acts like this is
the worst thing ever made and it's not
it's just a bad movie coming off the
heels of some of the most popular films
that were made as tiring as the constant
CG gets in this there are a lot of very
neat landscapes the worlds are very
creative and very beautiful to look at
the sword fights got a lot better to
remember when Darth Vader and obi-wan
were just kind of tapping those light
sticks together well now this is a
straight-on battle and it looks amazing
it's still impressive even years later
now where do you see it as a good thing
or a bad thing there is something
interesting watching a guy's dream
suddenly come to life with nobody
getting in the way it's a fully realized
vision with no filters whatsoever
and as someone that loves film and
artists it's interesting to see it just
so happens it's not very good
but it's still interesting was this
always planned from the beginning
probably not but it's also kind of neat
to see the changes he'd want to make and
yeah what happens when a filmmaker stays
away from his craft so long I can't even
make a small argument for the
midi-chlorians it's been proven that a
lot of people that seem to have a
spiritual essence are a lot of energy
the water in their blood is affected so
in a very slim way you could kind of
make the argument that this is credible
and doesn't get in the way of the
philosophical and religious aspects but
even I admit is very very slim I'm just
trying to offer an interesting point of
view but yeah like everyone I thought
this was a turtle's the story's too
complicated for kids to follow and the
dialogue is too childish for adults to
follow so unlike the original 3 where
it's book 2 both this one speaks to
neither I'm hearing more and more that
there are a lot of kids that grew up
with this because hey they like Jar Jar
they like poop jokes and they like a lot
of the visuals which is interesting when
you watch them grow up and realize that
the original three films were much
better than the
honestly the most entertaining thing
about this film is the fan reaction the
fact that people waited days in line and
then were in such denial when they found
out it was bad they didn't even admit it
was bad they tried to bargain with
themselves and be convinced that it was
actually good but over time nobody could
defend the poop jokes
nobody could defend the racial
stereotypes as much as critics at the
time actually tried to say this was a
good movie yeah look up the reviews at
the time they tried to defend it it
showed in full view the power of hype
and how long it took for so many people
to admit the emperor has no clothes
honestly in many respects it's kind of
an important movie for that it shows
that artists are flawed and there is no
perfect project hell even the original
Star Wars had a lot of stilted acting
and hokey dialog for a lot of fans this
was the bursting of the bubble the
ending of the fairy tale the having to
face real life but there's advantages to
that too
it tells people that hey you don't have
to be perfect to make good stuff you can
learn you can change things you can make
stuff better even your heroes aren't
always your heroes and that's okay you
can be inspired to do better work if
you're one of those people that claim
Lucas killed your childhood you never
had a childhood to begin with or you're
constantly trying to stay in it and
reject your grown-up world bottom line
he got his vision made and it sucked but
at least he got it made exactly how he
wanted it it still did well the box
office so you can't claim as a waste of
money but yeah after years of spin-off
books and spin-off games and so much
those be done with the Star Wars
universe that Lucas had little
involvement with did I expect a lot more
oh yeah but it's still such an
interesting turnout in how strange and
awful it is that it's kind of something
to analyze we'll never know was it just
too many Yes Man or was he away from
filming too long or was he never really
that talented to begin with it was just
other people that made it work it's one
of the great mysteries that's fun to
speculate and if you like it great I
wish I could have such an innocent mind
not to see all these offensive
stereotypes I'm sure he thought he was
doing some sort of clever commentary but
if you don't see how this movie can piss
off a lot of people enjoy
you're definitely part of a rare
minority and don't let anyone take that
away from you but for me and a lot of
other people it says if the voices of
millions of people cried out in terror
and were suddenly never given their
money back